hey everyone and Sara Thresh Turner
sorry and calm and in this video I'm
going to demonstrate for you how to
administer a transdermal patch
specifically fentanyl so what is
fentanyl finn'll is an analgesic it's
used to treat pain and in this case
patients who are using transdermal
patches need them because they have
chronic severe pain that isn't being
managed with Pio medications so the
transdermal patch will deliver this
continuous amount of medication over a
period of time so whenever you are going
to be administering fentanyl you want to
watch out for some things you want to
check the patient's respiratory status
because Pinto can cause respiratory
depression so the rest or esata snore
m'l also check their blood pressure
because it can cause hypotension and
assess the patient's pain rating and its
location and see how well the patch is
being effective and of course before you
administer the fentanyl patch you want
to do the patients v ride you need to
ask yourself do I have the right patient
do I have the right drug so you're going
to look at the physicians order you're
going to look at your past that you have
in hand make sure says spindle you have
the right dose and again comparing the
doctors order with what you have in hand
do you have are you administering it at
the right time and is this the right
route then you want to take take it a
step further and look at your package
make sure it hasn't been opened it's not
damaged or been tampered with
if it has you'll want to get a new one
and you'll want to look at the
expiration date each patch has an
expiration data when it expires to make
sure it's within date and since this is
a teaching video we are using a demo
dose so it's for stimulation only this
patch does not contain fentanyl it's
just to show you how to administer that
and of course I always follow proper
guidelines for administering medications
and with the proper credentials so first
what we're going to do is we're going to
remove the old patch and you want to
wash your hands and you want to dawn
gloves and it's very important you use
gloves for this because although this
patch needs to be removed because it's
expired time for a new dose it still
contains medication
you can get fentanyl on yourself so you
want to protect yourself from getting
residue from this patch and if you don't
know where the patch is you can look in
the Mahr to see where the last nurse who
administered charted it should say where
they put it typically they can be found
on the upper arms the upper chest or the
back sometimes on the flank so here on
this patient it is on the upper arm so
wash your hands run is on glove and
we're going to remove it and anytime
you're removing a fentanyl patch you
need to have another nurse witness this
with you especially the disposal part so
what you're going to do is you're just
going to gently remove the patch and
then you're going to fold it together
sticky side to sticky side like this and
then dispose according to your hospitals
protocol and because this is a narcotic
again you're going to need another nurse
to witness you disposing of this
according to your institutions policy
and then after you dispose it you can
clean the side with some soap and water
if it's left any residue because a lot
of times from where it's sticky lint and
old dead cells like to collect on the
site so you can just take a washcloth
and just with water and wipe the area
all so after removing the old patch now
it's time to sit on the new one and what
you want to do is you want to open up
the patch and you want to be careful not
to use scissors if you can help it
because you don't want to cut the patch
that's inside of it so just tear the
patch open like that and before you even
start to take it off you need to date
and time this and whenever you do this
you want to make sure that you're doing
it on the correct side because on this
opposite side is the sticky side that
you were removing the adhesive backing
so it's the front to make sure you're on
the right side so put the date sometimes
your pins don't like to ride on these
very well and put the time
into your initials after day we night
are going to dawn some more gloves
because remember we want to protect
ourselves from that fentanyl patch so
we're putting on and whenever you're
placing the pads you're not going to
place it back on that same site you
remove that you're going to rotate sites
so again you can use the upper chest the
other upper arm or the back and we're
just going to use that other arm and you
want to make sure that the skin is
completely intact doesn't have a rash
it's not broken and if it's really hairy
in this area you'll want to clip the
hairs don't shave but clip the hairs and
put it there don't put it over any
lotions or creams or anything like that
and you may if the skin is dirty or oily
you'll need to clean the skin with some
water don't use soaps or anything with
any type of lotions in it because it can
affect how well this patch stick also
another tip is if your patient is
confused you don't want to put it
somewhere where they can grab it off and
it gets lost and maybe they have a child
come to visit or someone they pick up
that patch not knowing what it is I
could get fentanyl on them so put it
somewhere where they're not going to
pick it off and try to pick an area
that's not going to have a lot of
friction on it or where it would easily
come off as well so we're going to apply
our patch over here and on most patches
when you slightly bend them the backing
will come off so gently take this part
of the backing and just hold it up
avoiding touching the back of the patch
place that on the skin and the other
piece will come off as well and here's
to the skin and make sure that is on the
skin there's no bubbles all the edges
are down it's good to just hold it
firmly down for about 20 to 30 seconds
to make sure coming into contact with
the skin correctly and if the patient
gets sweaty or over time to some these
are warm for several days you may have
to place some tape over it or a Tegaderm
works really well just to keep it in
place
then after you place your patch you'll
doff your gloves and washer
and you will chart it and it's very
important you chart where you place the
new patch so the nurse who's coming in
after you and a couple days to change
the patch will know where to find it
easily so that is how you apply a
transdermal fentanyl patch thank you so
much for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos